there's a lot we still don't know about
this virus the only way to stop it is to
kill it the Chinese they believe the
government lied to them they believed
that they knew about this was going on
for two months before they did anything
there's a lot of anger it became a
crisis it was just out of control
Italy waited too long South Korea
responded immediately 20% unemployment
may be a small number compared to war
could be six months from now we don't
want the airlines to go bankrupt the
consequence would be catastrophic
but you're still saying 18 months I
don't think that's extremely aggressive
because of the plays extremely
aggressive we didn't know yes how long
can we really sustain this younger
people are going to the bars they're the
most dangerous because they don't even
know they're ill how bad can this thing
yet right now the death rate in the
United States is 2% that's a lot of
people so we have the solution right now
with a drug to fix it what if it has a
side effect no one anticipated why don't
we do social distancing for those above
50 but below 50 let them go to work they
go back home they're infected and they
kill their parents and grandparents is
that what you're telling me let's kill
all the capitalist off we want all the
CEOs the vice president saying the
middleman
no I'm not saying you're say I'm saying
if you're my co I'd say dude go home
we're getting into the bath this is the
bath 80% of our drugs are dependent on
China this is a national security issue
that's very concerning for the average
person this is a real problem it's a
crisis it is not the apocalypse tell the
media dad did you ever think you would
make it take sweet victory I know this
life
yeah why would you fit on Goliath but we
got red tape value caiman given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't no value the haters honey run
homie look what I become I'm under one
[Music]
so look what the recent videos we've
been doing on coral and a virus many of
you guys were asking about if I can
bring a couple experts you to talk about
this pandemic so today I have with me
two guests one is Professor Andrew
natchios who was a former lieutenant
colonel for 23 years and I also have
with me dr. Parker who's a former
colonel in the military they both are
experts on the topic of pandemic and
I'll let them introduce themselves to
you on what they do professionally and
many different experiences they have but
I got a list of questions to go with
them so having said that let's get right
into gentleman thanks for coming out
thank you thank you so if you don't mind
taking a moment and just kind of
introducing yourself what you do you
know we'll take the lead from there you
can so I'm a professor professor in the
international program at the bush School
of Government at Texas A&M I run the
Scowcroft Institute of International
Affairs general Scowcroft was the
national security adviser to President
Bush 41 the older or shook just right
there is a couple of years ago before so
12 years I've taught I used to teach at
Georgetown University in the Walsh
school but for much of my career my
middle later career I was in
international development so what do you
do to help poor people in the developing
world in agriculture and health so I was
the administrator of the United States
Agency for International Development
which is the foreign aid program in the
US government that helps poor countries
and we've been doing that since 1961
President Kennedy created it President
Bush was one of our great heroes because
he tripled the budget for foreign aid
most people don't know that and his
program on malaria has cut malaria rates
in Africa of 50% in many countries and
the hiv/aids program he started has also
pushed back the hiv/aids problem in
Africa in other areas of the world so I
did that I was with World Vision the NGO
for five years as in the 1990s as a
vice-president so I have an academic
career I have a career as a as a aid
administrator and then I have a career
in state government Massachusetts where
I originally come from I was in the
state legislature for 12 years and then
I was chief operating officer for the
state and then I ran the Big Dig which
is a huge construction project in Boston
after there were
cost overruns scandal I had to fire a
bunch of people and it was a kind of a
big mess so I have three careers very
and you also work with dr. Fauci on HIV
well I worked with him 15 years ago
because he's the one that convinced
President Bush to start the program and
we worked with him and the Global Health
Program at AIG is its strongest
strongest sector that AI D works on as
projects all over the world and one of
the things we should have been doing is
mobilizing AI D to help people in Africa
Latin America the Middle East and Asia
in poor countries to deal with this
because they don't have a lot of support
without a ID and without some of the
other aid agencies the UN is over over
committed right now it's just w-h-o and
and the World Health Organization and
they need help so that's that they've
begun to mobilize Congress put a billion
and a half dollars in the budget that
just went through the president's sign
to do this so I'm happy but I think they
should have done it two months ago but
we got to get a picture and I got a list
that things I want to get it how about
yourself dr. Park so I would describe my
my career's public service public health
national security now I'm the director
of the pandemic and biosecurity policy
program in the Scowcroft Institute and
I'm also associate dean for Global one
health at Texas A&M
prior to joining Texas A&M about six
years ago I had 36 years and at the
federal level 26 years and the army
active army and a lot of lot of my
career was spent at the US Army Medical
Research Institute of infectious
diseases I was a former deputy commander
and commander affectionately called
Juice Amrit many people know it is that
and so I kind of cut my teeth on bio
defense high consequence emerging
infectious diseases from that experience
when I left the army I went to the
Department of Homeland Security and then
I was drafted and pulled quickly over
the Department of Health and Human
Services in 2005 about 30 days before
Hurricane Katrina hit and so I kind of
quickly pivoted to emerging infectious
diseases to things like healthcare
capacity and things like that they were
also dealing with a day and then
pandemic preparedness and so forth I was
a principal deputy as
a secretary at HHS four that's one of
the leading forces right now for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and my last tour in government service
is that the Pentagon is a deputy
assistant secretary for chemical and
biological defense and my career kind of
crosses over like with Andrew said with
Tony Fauci and when it's certainly when
I was in HHS and DOD but it goes back to
the anthrax letter attacks and in 2001
so it's fair to say you're both
qualified to talk on this topic which is
why we have you here so we're excited if
we do come out and spend some time with
that's why do I post a question
yesterday what questions would you ask
them and we got lists of question first
person I asked was my eight-year-old son
what question do you have about this
pandemic I said that the parkers gonna
be here so do you have any questions for
him I said is he related to Peter Parker
so forth
Transparency any relation to Peter
Parker can get no relations importance
you know that so let's get right into it
so good bad ugly a lot of people are
afraid I'm in the business world I'm in
the financial world I mean and we're
creating content and we have employees
agents clients everybody which there's a
lot of people that are afraid because
there's a there's this level of
uncertainty of people still don't know
what's really taking place from where
you're at on what you know what good do
you know about what's going on right now
progress bad and ugly so good bad ugly
you can start off with ugly or bad first
and then go to good if you want to but
you can you can restart I'll take a
start well I think actually one of the
good because we pivoted from a period of
what was called containment strategy
when the president actually imposed some
travel restrictions from China and at
that time that made a lot of sense and
we took a lot of actions to begin to try
to contain the virus so when we go back
to you know into January time frame and
that was essentially to buy some time to
start doing some preparedness and so the
organization's are going to be best
prepared the ones that took time to
start preparing back when the
containment strategy really began but
we've clearly hit an inflection point
where we clearly have translate
to a mitigation strategy plus
containment but in that mitigation
strategy is is really reliant on what's
commonly talked about now is flattening
the curve through social distancing
social separation interventions both
personal and at the community level so
what I would say is good about that that
people are taking it seriously and they
moving out actually with some government
guidance at all levels federal state
local but universities businesses
schools are taking action and people are
paying attention to it and they're not
necessarily waiting for the federal
government you know to tell them to do
something the guidance helps but I would
say that's part of the good that the
seriousness we are taking in the social
distancing interventions now we have a
long way to go and I know that's now
having a huge impact on on our economy
but we we know that and I would say also
that that is the good as well so we are
getting good guidance are we're getting
guidance from the federal state local
level on what it means to protect our
public health but we're also seeing a
lot of action to try to address some of
the economic impacts as well and so
we'll go into some of the bad later so
that's the good that's any good um well
I think there are basically three ways
of combating a pandemic one way is a
vaccine you don't have a vaccine will be
year and a half before we do we can't
wait that long I mean the consequence
would be catastrophic the second is
through medication that will kill them
by taking a pill you kill the virus
called antiretrovirals we call them
antibiotics for a bacterial infection
antiretrovirals for a viral infection
this is a virus we have a bunch of anti
retrovirals that already exist but they
don't know what it'll do to this virus
it could make things worse conceivably
not likely but conceivably we don't know
which one works better than the others
so they're testing them now and Jerry
tells me two to six months maybe there's
some promising antivirals that are
already approved FDA approved or under
it other indications
and the preliminary evidence that
suggests that some of these antivirals
may have época C against the cope it
Tsarskoe b2 virus and so clinical trials
have already begun to look specifically
at this this virus and whether they
would help clinically so this the social
distancing is not going to solve the
problem because as soon as you stop
doing the social if you get the
infection rate will go down if everybody
follows the instructions to do this
social distancing and quarantine and all
that so but but then when you stop doing
it it'll go up again the only way to
stop it is to kill it and you can kill
it through medication and later vaccines
to prevent you from getting sick at all
but that's not a sequential in terms of
timing so then you might have damage to
the economy and the number of people who
would die if we waited for the vaccine
is is that's not an option but we have
to do it because the permanent long-term
fix is massive inoculations around the
world and a vaccine so we're doing we're
doing the right thing now with limited
resources and a little bit of tools now
let me mention who is at risk because
the data is very very interesting this
coming out and there's more and more
data a lot of data from China and there
was a large study done that was
published in the American Medical
Association Journal
yes Journal of American Medical
Association by Chinese scientists they
we think our scientists believe if it
was legitimately done you know a lot of
the data I don't believe the data coming
out of China I think it's cooked because
the Chinese government's an autocratic
regime and they're using this crisis to
advance their strategic interests that
have nothing to do with the they're
using the crisis to push us aside and
say we we are the ones that should be
leaving the world not the United States
we can talk about that later but so but
we have data now out of Italy and Italy
and South Korea our democratic systems
their scientists are not going to be
ordered what to do they won't they
wouldn't follow it anyway but a study
came out yesterday from the very large
caseload in Italy which is now the
second largest of the world it is next
to China and I think they're 27,000
people infected and they've lost Lara
a large number it's the highest death
rate in the world 8% 8% South Korea who
is wave Freddie way ahead of everyone
else has only 1% doesn't now those
figures are going to change they both
have modern healthcare systems Italy
waited too long to respond South Korea
responded immediately South Korea tested
every one massive testing 250 thousand
tests that allowed them to target what
they were doing and the reason they did
all this is they had a SARS another
virus similar to this one that took
place 15 years ago they screwed it up
then and they fixed it the Koreans fix
their system or prepared form a pass
that's exactly correct very good news
yes preparedness does work if you do it
at the senior level with all the
ministries and there in the case of
South Korea or departments in our case
so now who is it risk the study says in
the one that just came out 99 percent of
the people who have died in Italy had
some other comorbidity which means some
other disease they had cancer they had
heart attack they had a stroke they had
diabetes they have autoimmune disorder
you said 90% 99% 9999 that's what the
studies say got it okay now the one
that's people have not talked about at
all I mean it's in the data and there's
a study in China and one that I saw that
is exactly the same but not the same
percentages that was done in will hand a
small sample the the group that is most
at risk are people who have hypertension
which means high blood pressure now we
looked up the data this morning
according to the Center for Disease
Control the preeminent group of
scientists the United States and the
federal government a hundred and eight
million Americans 30% of the population
have high blood pressure okay 30 million
should be on medication and they're not
and 75% of these people should be trying
to control their high blood pressure by
minimizing for example the amount of
salt they use exercising more not eating
fried foods for example I mean you can
lower your blood pressure without
medication but they're not doing that
obesity causes high blood pressure that
that contributes it to it a lot so 75%
of the people who died in Italy had high
blood pressure that was not being
treated okay so Jerry gave me an
explanation you don't want to go it's I
didn't even a said what he was talking
about is to why there may be a
biological connection between this virus
and high blood pressure and why that is
killing people so the advice is that
your blood pressure tested if you have
high blood pressure you should be on
medication maybe too late in your life
to do it because if you don't take the
medication you likely to have a stroke
or a heart attack with high blood
pressure if you know if it's not treated
properly exercise more a few if you
improve your lung capacity that will
also make your lungs stronger because
the other element of this is the younger
people are have very low rates they have
the same rate of infection but they have
very low rates of mortality under 40
very low in case of Italy most of the
people who died were over 60 years old
huge percentage were over 1600 60 years
old that doesn't mean younger people
can't get sick it means they won't die
from it now there is some evidence that
it can also damage your lungs if you get
it but you survive 20 to 30 percent
reduction in collectivism it's it's a
preliminary report all of it you know I
you know I I think we all have to be
caution to not focus on any given
statistic or any given literature
publication in a moment we are going we
there's a lot we still don't know about
this virus and we have to just
understand that and appreciate it but
every day we are learning so much more
about this virus you know and knowledge
the scientific knowledge about this
virus is extremely important to how we
guide our public health response and and
we just have to accept that right now we
are still in a data gathering mode it's
very similar to other outbreaks that
we've experienced including the 2009
pent h1n1 pandemic we are in somewhat of
the fog of war unfortunately but that
happens with all kind of serious
outbreaks this happen to be a really
serious outbreak
and a real potentially real serious
virus that we have to pay attention to
we don't have to worry I mean
worrying can be counterproductive we
have to be concerned about it I'd like
to go back and I'll go back and visit
the community mitigation sure a little
bit too and because - just to maybe show
some examples of why it's important at a
magnet loving mother were just out of
curiosity are we still on good or have
we gone to bat or have we not gone to
ugly yet we're still where I want to go
back to the maybe to the to the good
again and why community mitigation is
important and why flattening the curve
is is a real phenomenon and we could
just look at the macro level and and
without getting into statistics but look
at at China and the impact of kovat in
China and so where there were some
draconian draconian social distancing
measures put in place around first
around
whoo-hooo on and in the entire who may
province which included up to sixty
million people that was a complete
complete shutdown with a lot of you know
police control and invasion of privacy
and etc etc so we look at the that and
it would became a crisis it was just out
of control but when you look at the data
from the rest of China actually that
locked down of the who Bay Province
actually mitigated the severity of the
disease and the rest of China and so
that's just an example on a macro level
that these actually community mitigation
now that's trakone Ian we're never going
to do something like that and in our
country in most countries would not not
do that but then there's some other good
examples and so you look at Singapore
you look at Taiwan they have largely
mitigated the severe impacts they have a
lot of cases but they've been able to
mitigate some of the severe impacts and
the overwhelming of the hospital systems
and so forth and mitigated the number of
deaths but it was social distancing
essentially the community mitigation
social distancing in containment and
laboratory testing compare that to Italy
where professor not CEO has already said
they waited way too late and
community mitigation and we see the
results compared to Italy versus Taiwan
Singapore and South Korea some were kind
of in the middle but they jumped out at
two they had kind of unique case with a
diamond Princess cruise ship that was
part of you know what started there oh
no that was Japan I'm sorry I've got
that mixed up that was Japan but Japan
got a lot of elevated cases too but
South Korea had to do with the church in
Daegu but but what really helped South
Korea's professor not CEO said with the
extensive laboratory testing so they can
identify where there were hot spots in
their communities and do something about
it within in more aggressive in the
Commuter mitigation measures and so but
that those are just that the macro-level
can can give you an example of countries
that have done well versus those that
have not so doc you said that China took
the approach of draconian it was
extremely draconian so can you elaborate
what you mean by that for somebody that
doesn't know what you well you know I
would just say it's it's it was an
essentially a complete shutdown of and
forced forced quarantine of a population
of 60 million people and people were not
allowed to leave their house there was
an enhanced surveillance police powers
information was not flowing and so that
was I guess I would call the draconian
just something that only an authority
authoritative government like China
would do would or could do they put
paper on people's homes with tape and if
you break the tape and go outside the
police would come in so you could not
leave your house or you get into trouble
with with the police so what do you
think about the the threat that's going
around saying we may possibly be put on
a shutdown so if you're saying that
you're saying that there's no way in
America when we put on shut that because
I lived in Iran before what we weren't
curfew is shut down you can't even leave
the place and it was a law where the
government's going around looking at you
two suitors are doing right you're
saying that's not possible in u.s. 12
not like it was good not my paper now a
National Guard
not with the National Guard coming to
arrest us and in police powers it's just
it's we're not a best we're not a police
state instead now can we take some
aggressive just social separation
measures without having all the kind of
authoritative type of regime of course
we can't whole gressive well we we're
doing things like now universities are
moving to distance learning and taking
social distance these measures of some
industries and businesses are maximizing
work from home policies there are areas
where schools are closing down in fact I
think I heard this morning that one
state Kansas the governor decreed that
schools should close for the remainder
of the spring and so yes our classes
we're gonna do by we're gonna do about
distance learning also to do that are
you know we're or tourists reported to
do that and we can't travel abroad
there's no travel abroad and who is
ordering you there Provost of the
universe guy she's our ultimate boss
who's anybody at forcing her no no these
are just prudent measures under the
circumstances of with a public health
threat that globally is very high in
individual communities in the United
States you'll see some people say we'll
say in individual communities the risk
may be low but in some communities the
risk is already high and so we're gonna
have individual communities across the
United States are going to be impacted
at various different times this is not
going to just hit the United States all
at once it's going to it's going to hit
individual communities that's separate
times and so people are just taking some
prudent decisions trying to keep the
students the faculty in this case the
students and faculty safe and and
mitigate the loss of life but also
continue with the mission of Education
and so you know it that that to me is
not a draconian measure it's a very
prudent safe sound measure to continue
in this case our education mission keep
our students safe I read an article
yesterday from Goldman Sachs that was on
Forbes I believe that said on a call
with 1500 investors you know they
projected that you know
50% of America is gonna get coronavirus
about 150 million people are gonna get
coronavirus says the data they gave and
3 million people are gonna die because
of an odd there's this article you're
reading you've you've seen the number
being thrown around by other places not
just the same as or exaggerated right
some of them it's exaggerated now
there's the flip side is you know you've
heard about China slowing it down and
they're no longer getting the kind of
surge that they were getting but then
you came back and you're saying the fact
that that happened because they fully
shut everything down so social
distancing work but if you let them
loose because some of my friends said I
did a conference call at 1:30 today
saying people who were buying products
and they were doing their business is
based on minor products from China those
factories are not opening up you can
order from them again so now business is
back to usual for some place it's not
everywhere so the cases are not grown as
bad as they are so if the cases were
able to be controlled in China and we're
projecting that we may go to 150 million
if we don't take care of it you know if
you look at those numbers
you know how long can we really sustain
this if you go out to specific or social
distances you're usually using models to
project this and there's they're very
thoughtful people and they're sincere
people but Bob Cadillac who was a
Jerry's predecessor actually we gave him
a career award at our annual pandemic
summit we've been having pandemic
summits for five years by the way art
white papers are available on the bush
school website we've been predicting
this would happen not with AK reliable
oh by the way yes okay so we've been
saying this would happen we proposed a
bunch of things that we thought should
happen to prepare the country and when
the President signed the executive board
in 2018 on pandemics which was required
by the by statute he they took language
out of our white papers in put it in the
executive order so they know we were
reading it we passed it up to Congress
both parties and they followed some
things they ignored some things the hard
things they ignored that's what usually
happens but the point here is that once
the Chinese put people back in the in
the factories again it's likely that the
the infection rates going to go back up
again
it's like it was before but it could go
well go back up again and that we're
seeing that a little bit less Singapore
a little bit so we don't know whether
what's going to happen but there's some
people privately they're saying this you
know that the social distancing works as
long as you keep doing it but then you
can't do it forever now so the question
is how long this is going to last and we
don't know that we don't know that
yeah we don't know that but we know I
think we can take some lessons you know
what we're seeing in China they were
locked down and the case is now or you
know they're they're on the downslope of
that epoch curve and that was about two
months and so that that's what you're
seeing too with dr. pouchy who's really
our pre a preeminent person in the
United States he is talking about you
know an estimate and he freely admits
you know we don't know for sure but
that's the estimate that he's been using
that this made me you know two months do
to get to get on the on the real down
slope of this epi curve I was gonna
quote Bob Cadillac Gerry's successor
he's colleague rally friend but he said
that the models don't work and the
models that were predicting these three
million people but even if you take a
much more conservative view right now
the death rate in the United States is
2% so it's not 1% like Korea it's not 8%
like Italy it's 2% let's say it's gonna
be 1% because food she when he was
testifying before Congress he was 1%
that's a conservative estimate that's
still 10 times higher than the death
rate for the flu the flu is one tenth of
one percent so this is it's a
conservative estimate and if you say 20
percent of the people are gonna get
infected that's 66 million people say 1
percent of 66 million is 1.8 million
people that's a lot of people and some
communities will be hit harder than
others I was back just to make sure I
got the quote on the models right
because and it's essentially because
models can be very valuable as well yes
there is there are a lot of assumptions
you know the models are as good as
assumptions that go into it so going
back to what I said there's still a lot
of we don't know and so we're having to
put assumptions of what we you know what
we can estimate but at the end of the
day just like hurricanes you know when
we see a hurricane come out in the
Atlantic how
any different model projections are
there a whole bunch of them you know as
a hurricane gets closer to us then the
models start to converge a little bit so
it's kind of an Alex with that so you
know when we're seeing a hurricane way
out in the Atlantic Ocean all models
actually are very confusing but as it as
time as it gets closer those models
begin to kirker and and then they become
more helpful how bad can this thing get
how well let me let me let me yeah me
you know let me kind of go back to some
of the statistics too and why why we
need to be really clear concerned and
careful we've heard a lot up until kind
of recently the good news is what looks
like only 80% 81 percent of the people
it's mild and that is that is you know
the good news but the unfortunate news
it's 20 percent or not and so you know
actually going back to the biggest
cohort again from the Journal of
American Medical Association which was
published by China scientists but has
been through pretty thorough peer review
you know 15 percent of those are are
severe and many of those requiring some
level of hospitalization but some of
those in that 15 percent categories
slide into the critical care and that
critical care is requiring intensive
care ventilator support and so forth so
it's really that by percent number that
we should be concerned about and those
you know the more that we can keep those
in that that severe category from
sliding in the critical category because
once you slide into that critical
category that's almost a 50% mortality
and and and it's not just a disease of
elderly although those over sixty or one
of the vulnerable populations but
anybody that has one of these other
comorbidities and so we going back up at
the macro level in the United States
there's about a hundred and five million
people that kind of fall into the this
this vulnerable population category
seventy percent of that hundred five
million people are actually in the over
65 but 30% of them fall in this 18 to 59
year old category that happen to have a
colon comorbidity or underlying health
conditions so there there is a report
for getting them a anecdotally but
there's articles and this half
in Europe and the newspapers that
younger people below 30 are just
ignoring this maybe they read the data
that the very there by the way there's
no child under the age of nine has died
so there are children can get it and
they show they show symptoms but it's
not severe and they don't die thank
heaven we don't understand why that is
so the research eventually will tell us
why but younger people are going to the
bars there there's I heard reports of
comorbidity parties with a lot of kids
getting together now that's
irresponsible to do that but they should
think about their parents and their
grandparents because if they get sick
they can get members of their family who
are older who are over 60 sick and you
wouldn't want to be responsible for your
grandparents or your parents dying I'm
sure they're not even thinking of that
they said well I'm invulnerable I can't
die from this because I'm young and
healthy and all that well they could get
other people sick ain't get the
professor's sick can I worry about date
they could be an asymptomatic carriers
that that's right that's the other thing
they can people can carry the disease
and have no symptoms and not be sick at
all they're the most dangerous because
they don't even know they're ill and
that and there is some evidence not not
substantial evidence yet that there is a
sub and if whether it's a question of
whether it's a major driver of the
transmission probably not but it can
happen right interesting so you know are
you hearing about what UK is doing with
the herd immunity what are your thoughts
on that because you know somebody asked
the question they said well Pat if if we
know the cases below 50 the death rate
is below one percent in cases above 150
is higher why don't we do social
distancing for those above 50 well below
50 let them go to work because they're
not really being affected wise and so
when they come back home and their
parents are living with them and they
are under they're not going to die the
ones under 50 they go back home they're
infected and they kill their parents and
grandparents is that what you're telling
me that doesn't make any sense
the UK is doing that that's not a bad
it's not a good idea to verbalize I hope
we don't do it the United States how
familiar
well yeah let me let me let me actually
Mikkel back to models because this is
actually where I think models are that
has converged over the years just on the
application and non-pharmaceutical
interventions social distancing and so
the models have pretty much been an
agreement over the years particularly as
we studied pandemic influenza the threat
of pandemic influenza starting back in
the twenty 2006-2007 timeframe and then
applied into 2009 pandemic the community
mitigation or non-pharmaceutical
interventions measures interventions you
have to be pretty aggressive you can't
just pick one demographic not another
demographic you have to make sure that
you're doing things for industry
universities other non-government you
just can't piecemeal a community
mitigation measure because they're the
models tell you that's not effective and
that's essentially what you describe
from the UK would be kind of a piecemeal
approach to community mitigation trying
to socially separate one demographic
versus the others when in reality you
just can't do that you know and be
analogous at the end we can come back to
borders in a minute and why how borders
and border closures what what effect
they may have you know I'm stopping you
know ultimately stopping something but
we can come to that but it beats some
because but at the end of the days
viruses don't respect and no borders and
boundaries so there's so you so UK herd
immunity and you don't mind just explain
what well that's when you have enough
people in the population that that
having a unity o to a given virus that
the that there's immunity and the
transmission from the virus is going to
ultimately die out and that measles is a
good example that we know measles is
very infective and and you have to have
over 95% of the population needs to be
immune which means that's your your you
have to have a herd immunity in the
population of over ninety five percent
to really kind of stop transmission and
not have disease if I herd immunity
drops below 95 percent we will see
transmission of measles covet nineteen
we're not sure what it is yet but some
of the early studies say it's probably
in the 60s sixty five percent we don't
know for sure I'm just know but
statistic I'll throw out and so I don't
think what the measure of UK are gonna
do are gonna provide enough herd
immunity to stop transmission so they
want 70% of population to get it for
their immunity and can fight against it
and then they go back to business as
usual so let me go back to what I was at
let me to the other problem with current
immunity by getting the disease does not
always guarantee you won't get it again
right and they're there they we don't
have enough scientific research at this
point to conclude that getting that most
diseases if you get one you build up
antibodies and if you get the disease 10
years later you you you your antibodies
will kill it but we don't know that
because some viruses that is not the
case and so they're making some
assumptions that are my view they're
very dangerous very dangerous very
dangerous assumptions the assumptions
they're making is very dangerous yes so
let me let me ask you to flip side on
this so you're saying are you willing to
go to work and get the virus and bring
you back and god forbid somebody that's
about 15 your family that lives with you
and ends up getting the virus right
that's what you said okay so the the
flip side to that is if you're saying we
cannot get a vaccine for 18 months I
know they did the testing on a vaccine
in Washington and I think they did 40
following them a couple days ago they
keep testing and then they're saying
it's a record-breaking time you're what
president Trump's just said a couple
hours ago that fastest record break in
town of the progress they're making etc
etc but you're still saying 18 months
for sure yeah absolutely
and so the record what it is record
breaking progress that we're making in
vaccine development and and we're today
we're able to use new tools that our
sense of allowing us to design a new
vaccine candidates the operative word
here is Canada based on means options
based on the the the genetic sequence so
the operative word candidate that means
it's still an experimental phase and so
the good news is at least you know
there's at least what I've seen in the
data there's at least 20 companies
universities are the 20 vaccine
candidates in development from private
secretary universities so that's 20
vaccine candidates going in in some
phase of very early discovery
development and beginning to go into
from preclinical to clinical phase one
studies phase one studies just
the first clinical study there's a phase
2 study that follows a phase 1 study
there's a phase 3 study that follows a
phase 2 study and the phase 1 is only
looking at safety is there any untoward
safety observations in a very small
study of humans phase 2 is a larger
cohort maybe 200 and maybe 5 to 200 to
500 people and it's been the and the
vaccine candidate is produced at a
little bit larger scale under good
manufacturing quality control standards
and it also looks at safety but it
begins to look at does the vaccine
produce an effective immune response
it's not it's not tested in in against
the virus in a hot spot phase 3 is is
then when you begin to use a more
commercially scalable type manufacturing
process for that vaccine candidate
that's still an experimental stage and
put it in a larger population to really
look at clinical efficacy in a in a hot
spot and to see whether the vaccine is
working against the virus those stages
in that manufacturing the advanced
development manufacturing and quality
control take a long time and it's hard
to shorten that out so the projections
of what dr. Fauci says it is probably
going to be 12 to 18 months before we
have a vaccine that's deployable
deployables and moves from a vaccine
candidate experimental to a licensed
product or a product that can be used
under emergency use authorization where
we have enough confidence that the
vaccine doesn't cause untoward
side-effects and it might have época see
those those things we can't shortcut
those those steps because if you do one
that it's only 75% effective and there's
another one that's 92 percent effective
don't you think we should know that
before we start selling the thing this
stuff and you want to make sure it
doesn't have safety problems exactly
what if it has a side effect no one
anticipated I mean you you want we were
on the military guys and you know we
were getting all these vaccines properly
you're taking this and you know there's
risk that later on you can have a
three-unit third ear on your forehead
but you know your associate their
property wait wait
I remember I was a military medical
research and develop test engaño we were
testing most of those vaccines um that
our soldiers including me received were
licensed there was a period in the Gulf
War that some were used on an emergency
investigation that to us of the Gulf War
and an investigational do drugs status
but there's been there was decades of
abuse and laboratory researchers like me
that told us that you know we understood
the safety profile and the efficacy
profile but the vaccines that we get in
the military have been FDA licensed it
was just you know we didn't like it
because we were getting a lot of shots
at one time as what we didn't like
here's a question for you here's a
question for you so if you're saying 12
to 18 with 25 he's saying 12 to 18 and I
agree with him I don't think that's
extremely aggressive because of the
phase extremely aggressive we didn't
know yes yes but let's just say they can
pull it off because Trump's going to put
pressure on them and they're gonna give
it 20 months okay fine at what point or
do you think best-case scenario we'll
have it ready that if we have a million
cases we can give a million people
vaccines it could yeah we don't give it
to them one yeah they have the you give
it to a before they get sick so it's
like a flu shot so at some point so then
that means you have to give it to a
hundred million people it's arriving at
two million well right let me let me let
me put a perspective so some point in
this of this development of phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 there could be some
point in a phase through 3 area where
we're beginning to see that we're not
seeing untoward side-effects or safety
issues and we're seeing some evidence
that's that's effective there could be a
point before it's actually licensed if
everybody you know the scientific
community it would come to a conclusion
that maybe this vaccine can we can go
ahead and begin to use it before it gets
FDA license under what's called an
emergency use authorization because
there is growing evidence and sufficient
data that would warrant its safety and
efficacy in a in a with the risk an
elevated risk
now there wouldn't be probably the the
scale that might mean he needed but we
could also then think about who would be
prioritized to get a vaccine in Hyundai
and in limited quantities in hotspots
and so who would that be well you know
we we are putting our health care
workers in on the front line of this and
so we would have to think about you know
is that our health care workers is it or
is it is it the the population it's you
know most at risk but those are some of
the kind of ethical questions that would
have to be addressed you know at that
time and we're gonna have some ethical
questions right now and just you know
Hospital preparedness as well so so let
me ask you a question
here's cases okay I'll just give you
cases the number on how it's doubling
you've seen this before this is okay so
I got a question for you with what we're
seeing with charts on assuming these
cases keep doubling and I ran it at four
days six days and 10 days and this is
just us in four days if it doubles every
four days we're looking at eight million
cases by May first just in us but you
said that's too aggressive four days
let's take it to six days six days we'll
be at four million by May 19th okay if
it's six days four million that's still
a big number my by five nineteen if it
doubles every ten days we're looking at
September fourth all of us July second
four million cases if we have four
million cases and we use the 2% number
four million two percent 80,000 80,000
is seven times bigger than what we had
with the H 1 V 1 in in 2009-2010 with
Barack Obama we have about 57 million
cases I don't know the exact number we
had quite a bit so if we're going this
direction okay if we're going this
direction and we're looking at the
numbers that way it's gonna double at
that rate okay we don't have the vaccine
we're not gonna have it for 12 months to
give it to people 12 to 18 months what
what are we doing they have the drug
that's why that's why it's right
actually you know we I think you're
putting way too much emphasis so just on
a vaccine solution and that's why so we
have the solution right now with a drug
to fix it no not now you're putting way
too much emphasis on a medical
countermeasure as the fix
right now because public health measures
Archie tried and true and we're talking
about the community mitigation community
social distancing measures are going to
be very effective and they're buying us
some time until the antivirals or the
vaccine become on so next question so
the that's why what we're doing right
now in the social supports community
social distancing interventions are
essential because those numbers are kind
of frightening you're all you're also
assuming we'll know the numbers because
we have enough laboratory diagnostic
capability but that's another you know
and that's another you know we can talk
about that in a minute but but you're
you're really explaining kind of the you
know the the classic rules of
Epidemiology and and the the doubling
and replication and this is where we are
still in an exponential growth phase of
what we can see of what they say
exponential growth so this is not a
linear growth it doesn't go from one
case to two case three it doubles and
then it doubles again the doubles
against that's the that's what
exponential means and that's very
dangerous that's why there's a huge risk
to this Jerry is and this is where we
might disagree okay I think that I don't
think the American people in a democracy
are going to take are going to show the
disciplines particularly younger people
to to implement they should I'm not
saying they shouldn't I'm saying there I
think we have trouble with it after two
or three months of oh yeah we can't go
that long yeah and if we don't have
drugs that can kill the virus by the end
of that period we're going to have
trouble so I think the most important is
not to focus on the vaccine the
president is focusing the vaccine that
and my view that's a mistake because
it's too far into the future the the the
measure that's going to relieve us from
and the economy from this the damage
that's being done is these drugs that
already exist they're simply testing
them to see whether they're effective
against this disease that is what is
going to allow us to relax these social
measures that are are are the thing to
do now and we need to emphasize to young
people they cannot simply dismiss this
and go to a bar and have fun with their
friends that is does not work
defeats the whole purpose of this if
people behave that way
III think that part's fine and I think
they'll adjust to that with the bar part
because you know yesterday I'm going to
eat something lunchtime I going let me
go to a neighborhood services Oh close
let me go - it's closed then I want to
hop daddy
we're closed but we can you can order
we'll bring the food outside okay it's a
sit-down place but I sat outside they
brought the food I took the food I came
to the office okay that works the bar
start shutting down people know Friday
Saturday night you know that my concern
isn't that so so what the good news you
just gave is that because so many people
are just talking about vaccines and
we're relying on this vaccine it's
putting the fear in people assuming
that's gonna take 12 to 18 months that's
very concerning for the average person
were saying we made that the
entrepreneurs and scientists if they
team up together they can come up with
the right medication to help slow it
down or you know do anything to it and
maybe the people get it and that could
happen that real list now the problem is
an exporting problem is even if they do
all this science there is the issue that
the Chinese have effectively by
subsidizing their pharmaceutical
industry over the last ten years have
bankrupted our pharmaceutical companies
that produce the basic elements is
called API active pharmaceutical
ingredients we're getting to the bat
again this is the bat this is very
peasant of you or not ugly
it's okay so this quite ugly right yes
call China rx we didn't write the book
okay and it's on this subject it's been
a systematic attempt to bankrupt not
just American companies Japanese
companies European companies from
producing pharmacist 80 percent of
German drugs are dependent on China 80
percent of our drugs are dependent on
China so if the the pandemic continues
in China and you're Xi Jinping what are
you gonna do export all those drugs to
the United States and Europe no you're
gonna keep them inside the country and
treat your own people I would expect him
to do that but we have allowed this to
happen this is a national security issue
I am for free trade I actually believe
globalization is a good thing because
it's taken millions of people out of
poverty it's reduced costs it's improved
the quality of products it's made a
globalized world a lot of people hate
cap
I'm not one of those okay however we
don't allow our defense our weapons
systems to be produced in other
countries there's a reason for that
because is a national security question
we need to produce those weapons in the
United States for our military we need
to do that for pharmaceuticals as well
as well as as Jerry said earlier medical
disposables like the face mask we don't
have enough ventilators now so there are
measures that affect the survival of the
American people and there needs to be a
complete rethinking of this now did the
pharmaceutical companies deliberately
try to bankrupt themselves of course not
they didn't do that the Chinese did it
by subsidizing their own pharmaceutical
companies to become the dominant force
in pharmaceutical active pharmaceutical
ingredients which are necessary to make
the drugs for the whole world not just
for us and we need to dress this issue
and that's not for right now but it's
it's soon we need to deal with it soon
because if we get the drugs
the question is we get the drugs
approved through these scientific tests
we then have to produce them BAM we well
what can we produce them I don't know I
don't know which drugs mine that's where
we'll find up when you say I don't know
what do you mean you don't know like we
literally don't know no I'd say we've
just lost
we've offshored a lot of our
pharmaceutical manufacturing biologics
or vaccines antibodies not all but we've
all soared a lot a lot of our actual
manufacturing we have a very very strong
research base in the United States and
kind of early discovery and early
development but we we've offshored a lot
of a lot of manufacturing and we need to
bring it home so one and you know I'm
gonna say something about the vaccine
too because we we need to disco vid
vaccine that is being developed well one
of these candidates is going to be
successful I hope and we need to make
sure that we whatever whatever one is
successful or several that are
successful we need to make sure we're
manufacturing here at home and in this
vaccine will be important in 18 months
or whenever it does get license because
there many believe that the you know we
will get through this I mean there's
going to be this epic curve if it's two
months but it may come back and it may
become endemic
you know and like other viruses have
become and that's when the vaccine is
going to be very important if it does
become an endemic can you break that
down for somebody - so yeah so if we
look at compared to influenza and so we
have many circulating strains of the
influenza virus and it's a it's a flu is
a flu and so we have flu is all these
different strains are endemic in our
society and and every year we have to
really develop a new flu vaccine every
year based on the circulating strain of
flu any given your given season and so
flu is endemic it continues to continues
- excuse me evolve genetically and
that's why a new vaccine is always
always needed so this virus may act
similarly to that we don't know yet but
because it is circulating around the
world already almost every country now
is got corona virus and we're probably
not going to be able to completely get
rid of it and so therefore it will
probably be you know in in in our at a
much lower level and it may peak up at
some times but that's a vaccine is going
to be very very critical for us to have
in case it does become endemic usually
is a population we're kind of getting
back to some you know herd health and
population will begin to develop you
know some immunity just by natural
exposure to it and some of the
population will become you know well if
we were to get infected then hopefully
our signs are less severe in the future
so it sounds like you like what UK is
doing I mean you you go not not urgently
not this one a long time okay so so in
other words what you were talking about
is the fact that the virus is constantly
evolving so if it's constantly evolving
we have to also make sure the vaccine is
constant well that will be so we don't
know enough about the co vid and it may
not evolve as rapidly as what does
measles is a very stable doesn't doesn't
evolve it's pretty much so if you if you
had measles when you're a kid yeah and
you didn't because you didn't get the
the the immunization a vaccine you're
not going to get measles the rest of
your life because the the the your
bought your you know where your
they fought it on that's right and
they've developed an e but you know
where we store our in I did not know
this until my wife became ill we start
store our antibodies in our bone marrow
so our army our Marine Corps our one Oh
first airborne is in our bone marrow and
when a disease when when the disease
comes out the the army of antibodies
says this is disease and you're gonna
kill this thing and they march out and
they searched all over our whole body
and they kill all the viruses so that's
the whole idea of a vaccine you want to
build up the antibodies before you get
the disease so you don't have to get it
to develop the inner two ways to develop
the antibodies you can get a vaccine
which doesn't give you the disease or
you can get the disease and that's how
you get protection let me go back to the
question with the medication you were
talking about how fast if we are
absolutely crushing it how fast can we
come out with some kind of a medication
to help with coronavirus I think that's
gonna be very fast I'm not gonna give
you a month other than a range and maybe
two to six months two to six and and and
that's what I'm here and that's because
it's we're able to repurpose antivirals
that are already FDA license or in
development well down the development
pipeline for other indications other
disease other diseases right okay so
yeah and that's that's those are some of
the estimates I've heard from from
others as well but that's only because
there there are t license for another
indication and initial data looks like
they may be effective against kovat and
so these could be repurposed relatively
quickly if all that you know the
clinical trials you know prove out to
what what the data right now i don't
know the information of you know how
available how much you know how large a
manufacturing base is for those
antivirals
but I know that that has to be being
looked at right now very very serious
okay so you're saying you started off
with the good news and you've gone back
to the same ward multiple times both of
you you're sticking to your guns social
distancing social distancing social
distancing right that's the only tool we
have at the moment
is it fair to say you're above 50 what
do you mean age-wise oh I'm in the
vulnerable population so if you're
saying social distancing why are you
sitting so close to me and why are you
getting Wales to five other people here
as you're human in people who may listen
to your program and listen to her advice
and stop infecting other people by
listening to a Giri and I are saying in
terms of social distancing we didn't
drive three more hours up here just to
be seen on TV we go on the TV all the
time but your program is devoted to this
and we're hoping some people will take
the advice particularly younger people
and be more restrained in interacting
with people and by the way the
president's instruction which comes from
CDC from from our scientists a group
smaller than ten we have not met ten
people today we do five all the people
we hate before we came we're gonna eat
when we get back home okay
so so this leads me to the question I've
been trying to ask you this entire time
so if we go at this pace social
distancing okay so if if profits for
companies go lower and lower and lower
and lower you know what happens
companies have to layoff right so you
saw the article on CNN which the experts
are talking about unemployment can go to
20% I'm sure you've seen that okay so
when's the last time we saw 20% a long
time ago we're talking about great
depression 20% okay so you look at this
and you say okay there's two communities
you know how they say people vote with
their pocket you know how they say
people vote with their pocket I think
people also do research or data or
anything also with their situation let
me explain it and please challenge me
here for wrong okay so if I'm 70 years
old or if I'm 60 years old I'm probably
telling everybody social distance okay
but if I'm thirty years old and I got a
wife and two kids and I got a $2,500
mortgage payment I got a job in expenses
but only $25,000 on the bank I can plant
social distance for too long yes so I'm
sitting here watching these 67 years
keep on saying
social business social distance you
already have your pension you already
have a million dollars that's gonna pay
you for the rest you already rely on a
retirement from the military you can
social distance I can't social business
you put me in a tough position what do
you say to that my way of saying racing
this person most people don't work for
themselves they work in an institution
who's the CEO and the vice president
they're probably older people because
people have to have experience to run
you start killing off the people who are
running American industry now some
people who are hostile to the American
system say oh let's kill all the
capitalist off we want all the CEOs the
vice president saying the middle Banat
no I'm not saying you're saying saying
if you're my so I'd say dude go home go
state you go home let us run the company
we got jobs we got to make money but
don't because you because they cannot
isolate themselves from every single
older person in the society it does not
work they cannot ice up no I'm not
talking about isolating yourself
I'm telling you if the seventies we have
to if if you're telling the rest of us
anybody over 50 years old or 60 years
old that they should stay home this
whole time that's what you're saying no
no you're saying social distance I'm
saying say social distance to people
about 50 but the people that are less
than 1% risk of dying let him continue
the economy going because if we have 20%
of unemployment you know what comes
after 20% on the corner if you go to
look at the cities that is the highest
level crime what did it have in common
well I I know what you're thinkin not a
consequence yeah this could be so the
risk we're taking is we're assuming we
know how bad this thing could be we have
some data to show based on the cases
that it's less than 1% for people about
below 50 maybe UK is taking a decent
approach that we ought to consider what
people below 50 that's all I'm saying
so if you are the CEO of a company in
your 70 listen sir thank you so much for
the job you're starting you reference
the problem is there are a lot of people
under 50 which is what we're seeing in
Italy now there's an uptick of people in
their early 40s and late 30s being
hospitalized Italy with severe
consequences from this a professor told
me that that's due to high blood
pressure because of 75% I don't I need
some currency to this professor yes how
many of the 30% of Americans who have
high blood pressure are younger and how
many Americans are obese you know many
Americans are obese
and they're not old men you're right
okay it's a very big number
I can't dispute that so there are people
and people that gets cancer who are
young they have they have hiv/aids I
mean they may be on introvert or virals
now for that okay so there are people
with other comorbidities other diseases
diabetes that make them more vulnerable
and and they are underage it's not just
by age it's not just by age it's also by
with these other diseases big factor of
it is also age though when you look at I
know you what you're saying I know I saw
the asthma part the high blood pressure
you know obesity you're seeing this data
that's coming up yes but you know
there's still an opportunity to continue
the economy going if we got some people
that can go back to work and continue
their jobs because you know we had a guy
that called me says hey Pat we had one
of our guys he says we had a person that
was here who they take a lot of what he
called the students that come here that
they're not from us but they live with
them what what did international foreign
exchange students right yeah so foreign
exchange students staying with us and
one two foreign exchange students that
stay with them was from China right so
next thing you know he came here he went
and visit a family came back somehow
some way didn't get in karma buyers so I
said okay you know I I had it what did
it feel like dried coffee you know etc
etc I was feeling the same thing it was
two weeks it was stronger than the flu I
kind of had no clue what was going on
then I realized that's what I had but
I'm over it
and I experienced it I'm gone right to
me my wife and I are talking please
challenge me on this as as much as you
want I am Who I am wanting you to
challenge and what about to say here my
wife and I are sitting down I said babe
listen here's what's gonna change this
challenge that we're facing today okay
and this isn't even my main question I
wanna ask you to cinch at them I made
question I'm gonna get to here in a
minute I said babe the world has to see
thousands of people get coronavirus on
the news on TV on youtube doing a video
saying I have coronavirus here's what it
feels like this is what I'm going
through
here's what I'm doing so if anybody's
watching is they got coronavirus the
best thing you can do to help the world
is documented and put it on YouTube so
we can see what you're going through
here's a symptom this is my
this is what I weighed this is my height
I need to be this way I've have been
diagnosed with high blood pressure I've
never been done with without blood
pressure that has given us Intel so once
the world Tennessee's all this data in
comes back and says okay it's a virus
it's bad we got to be careful but you
know what we can get past it if we get
it as well so then comes the acceptance
that we can overcome it if we do get it
what is your thoughts on the way I'm
viewing this because any other way I'm
seeing us going like this till the end
of the year because if we don't find
this in the next six months 20%
unemployment may be a small number
compared to work could be six months
from that well every epoch and you've
seen you've seen dr. fad you talk about
this it's this epic curve and and what
we're trying to do is is flatten that
curve because the consequences of that
curve being very rapid and very steep is
that you are gonna have a lot of people
from the 18 to the over 60 they're gonna
fall in this critical category and we
are going to have a higher death rate
whatever the H may be and we're gonna
have our hospitals overwhelm and you're
gonna have positions have to make
extremely difficult decisions who lives
and who dies and and and actually I
would I think it would be good idea if
you could probably interview some
children and young kids from Italy who
actually probably had to deal with their
parents dying in Italy to Cove it and
probably not even you know to see their
parents buried and so this dis gonna
have you know huge impacts on kids and
young people when they're gonna when
they lose their family members and so
that's you know something that needs you
know to be thought about as well you
know I get your point you know and I you
know you know the economic impacts and
and younger people it's a very very good
good question but I also don't want to
see our country end up where we have our
ICUs and our hospitals just completely
overwhelmed and we're having to make
decisions and about who lives who dies
and crisis standards of care and that
that would be a fundamental shock to our
country we got into that kind of
situation and that's what's happening in
Italy right now that's
difference between an 8% death rate in
Italy which is extremely high it's three
times higher than the flu was in 1918
and a 1% rate less than 1% rate in South
Korea and remember we don't know really
what the true death rate is right now
because we don't know what the
denominator that means we don't know
exactly how many number of cases there
are because we don't Italy has more
diagnostic capability than we do but
even if it's 1% in a given community
that can overwhelm a hospital systems to
a system in a given community where you
were attending physicians and so forth
are having to make these these very very
horrible kind of decisions you South
Korea is fine because I think they're
number 2 in the amount of hospital beds
per thousand people they have and Japan
is number 1 on the list for I think 13
point O 3 I think South Korea was a 12
point O five and a u.s. is like 2.8 bets
per thousand we have nine hundred and
twenty-four thousand one hundred beds of
which 65 60 something percents being
used we only have 300 thousand available
beds and then outside of that the
ventilators the machines that we keep
hearing about that we don't have that
many that available New York Times today
yesterday just said that we New York
needs 18,000 of those in the next two to
four weeks so that's that part I fully
see as a big challenge of not having a
capacity to hand and I don't know who's
gonna run those ventilators you know the
other part is the health care workers
having the respiratory technicians
having the you know the pulmonologist to
worry about that part you know I don't
worry about that part because we do two
of you have experience where you know in
the field in the in the other day they
interviewed a sergeant major of Iraq
Iraqi military he was a 19 year old
sergeant major Sahel are you 19 year old
sergeant major says when Saddam fell and
Iraq started the new military they only
had 25 soldiers and nobody wanted to be
a sergeant major because you were the
number one person they wanted to kill
and I said I'll do it so I became a
sergeant major you know how on back in
the days hey you're a corporal I haven't
done the correspondence you're now
sergeant hey you're a sergeant you know
people were getting promoted in war so I
think that's that's not really the big
concern from Mayon do you think that the
the way I'm processing this with the
economy is are we comfortable the
economy fully going into shambles like
you know the part that the part that
concerns me I remember in army I think
you had to be younger than 35 to join
the army and the reason why I remember
this I had a guy in my camp and my boot
camp who had been in the Army before he
got out but it had been 10 years since
he got back into the army because you're
like $40,000 of credit cards and an army
agreed to pay off his $40,000 a credit
card but he was 34 and he told me the
age was 35 right so why is it 35 why
can't a 50 year old go to boot camp
right a 50 or doesn't go to boot camp
but in military system we just don't
want a 50 year old go into boot camp we
want the oldest 35 and if you think
about going to war how many people go to
frontlines it's not that a 40 year old
it's not a 50 year old this is the 22
year old 18 year old 11 Bravo that's
gonna be a different line why not treat
it the same way let the younger guys
that are driving the economy let them go
to work and do their part if their
immune system is that strong to it
because if we don't and this thing goes
the way it is you know you know one of
the things that's going to happen here
American capitalism there's a reason why
it's a superior system to government-run
businesses in China for example is they
they are extremely adaptive for example
business I restaurant my oh my the
Greeks are in I'm a Greek American the
Greeks dominate the the restaurant
business the United staring ways now to
say ok you can't come to our restaurant
choose what you want online and we'll
deliver it and I'm getting more and more
emails from the restaurants my wife and
I like to go out to eat and we haven't
started doing it we're gonna start doing
that ok so there are ways to adapt I
thought all the universities are gonna
have to be closed I learned how to use
zoom I did not know how complex but you
can run an entire classroom from your I
want to be had we have to have etiquette
because the professors were saying some
of the kids did not know that you could
see them and they were the men weren't
wearing shirts you know or they had
inappropriate pictures on their walls
and or the woman the man men okay it
because you can see the picture
everybody can see you have a guy who at
hector's his name he likes to wear two
tank tops okay well I'm going to tell my
kids are going to be properly dressed
and no inappropriate pictures on the
walls of the room in which they have the
zoom going on these are sort of
etiquette things never even occurred to
me but I get training for two hours
yesterday and I'm 70 years old I'm
adapting to this new distance learning
they call it I never thought I would use
distance learning but I am gonna do it
Monday morning so so and we're not we
understand the economic impacts back
this is gonna be part of our our
research in the pandemic and biosecurity
Policy Center for years is trying to
understand the economic impacts of this
we have to we have to find ways to try
to mitigate the economic impacts it's
not going to be easy they you can't
separate the two these are gonna be
tough challenges and the administration
actually is trying to find you know new
measures they are and in Congress they
are they are beginning to address this
is he going to address everything I'm
sure it's not are we gonna address
everything we need to do for the co vid
from a public health medical perspective
I'm sure we're not you know and so both
have got to be tackled and tackled very
aggressively so so so I'll give you the
flip side again I'm gonna keep challenge
you guys I've been challenged by doctors
and professors my entire life the joy
it's like I we do tonight I this is what
I look forward to okay so you said
Greeks restaurants we're gonna do it
this way teachers you're seven years old
yesterday you're learning how to do zoom
and you got to make sure that these guys
put a shirt on before you can teach them
what am i guys are hard time I'm gonna
hear from but but how do i zoom someone
on a plane to New York how do i zoom a
gym that is filled with so much metal
what they're saying that the corona
virus can live in a metal for 12 to 24
hours how do how do gems zoom you know
how how do many businesses that you have
to zoom I mean I understand zoom and if
I'm a personal trainer I'm fine I
understand if I'm an accountant and I'm
zooming I'm fine
I even think doctors can zoom because
there's business models right now that
is built on that but sure
not even business yeah not every result
I know I understand so so so how do you
explain that to the flight attendant
that's making fifty nine thousand
dollars you're hearing there have to be
federal intervene
and that's what they're talking but I
have to say given the very very partisan
nature and polarization of our political
system I am shocked yes I'm pleased and
how much the Democrats and Republicans
are getting together to address this
challenge now the the partisan ranker
seems to actually have diminished like
it did during World War two so they are
beginning to get stuff that is a great
thing you're saying like cuckoo Moe you
know governor of New York and tweeting
out and you know you never thought I was
gonna take place ever drop so so I think
when you're challenged with something of
this magnitude then people start getting
together and they're they there's a lot
of things that can be done if people put
aside the egos and the partisanship now
it's unfortunate it's a presidential
election year but it is that's what it
is and that's the way it is but I still
didn't answer my question though well
but but some of these things you cannot
fix the airlines are in big trouble we
don't want the airlines to go bankrupt I
understand that you saw boing-boing
needs a bill that way I am I am in I I
go in planes all the time so does jeredy
traveling traveling so we don't want the
planes go bankrupt in the economy
recovers we need the airlines to be
whole so there are a lot of things that
have to be considered this is not
businesses have to be considered what
the consequences for small businesses in
the United States I'll give you two last
crazy it's it's not going to go on
forever we are it's not it's not gonna
go on forever but we gotta mitigate its
severity we got to mitigate the economic
impacts no doubt about it if we don't
find a medication for month to two
months from now and vaccines not here
for 12 to 18 months and they're still
preaching social distancing and nod
they're paying $1,000 a month to every
American that that idea was brought up
by Andrew yang which was a back and add
a negative tax that Milton Friedman used
to talk about it's right I mean you know
then oh it's going to be another month
and another month and another month
right we're the social distancing the
peak there's always in an outbreak it's
going to go up and it's going to come
down and we are trying to mitigate the
peak of that that outbreak so it's lower
and the social distancing measures are
going to be needed long just long enough
to
lower the peak before they can be pulled
off social mess interventions are not
going to need to be going until we have
an antiviral till we have a vaccine
because the the peak will come down at
some point when there's enough people
infected but we so at some point they're
gonna we're gonna be able to pull these
off but right now we need to be really
aggressive and we have to you know think
in terms of weeks rather than days so
the orthodox church I go to
Orthodox never change anything it's the
same as it's been in the first century
which is why I like it okay all right we
have a young priest and I said father
you know we can't have services now the
archdiocese has said no services all the
altar boys and the choir and the priest
that's it I said well what about the
rest of us he's putting in a maybe I
shouldn't say this with me here he's
putting in a TV camera that we can all
participate in the divine liturgy which
is very calming thing if you're in if
you're under severe stress your
religious devotion makes a difference
calms people down hundred percent so
he's gonna put in a very inexpensive and
you're gonna you're gonna in real time
now we won't be able to take the
Eucharist but it is it you know it's a
it's a very innovative way of using
technology my wife's Catholic she's
doing that they're her church is doing
the same thing as the priests of the
Catholic side like has the level of
forgiveness gone up like are they a
little bit more Union right now than
before like father I have seen as I've
listened right now everyone's forgiven
don't worry about it
but you know if your if your priest is
able to zoom heaven that's game so you
know my concern with the economy is is
I'm just you're in the world and I'm
trying to see what you're thinking about
with this whole thing because you know I
also remember there was a time where
under another administration I think was
a 2011 or 12 where unemployment benefits
were paying out for 24 months if you
remember was 24 months and then they
kept saying well people can't have a job
and at the moment
I went to 12 months mixing and everybody
started to find jobs and getting jobs so
my concern is also people are not
working and we're just kind of
subsidizing and they're getting whatnot
you know giving them money and they're
taking care of everything for them then
when it comes back down to going and
work then they're not used to working a
40 50 hours a week what are we going to
do after that but the data shows from
previous epidemics that it's a Veeck
it's a V or V some of the economy
collapsed and it bounces extremely
quickly back up again it's not like we
had structural huge structural
prophesying that in 2008 this is not the
same thing as 2008 it took years to
rebuild the financial system we're not
facing that in this case that's innate
is greed who doesn't it has nothing to
do with this this is it I know this is
more 9/11 than it is that is exactly the
point yeah that's exactly we're not
facing a ten year recession or a five
year recession it's it's going to be a
quick rebound after we get control of
this so that's good news we got good
news that's a very good we got some good
news on this you know guys I'm hoping
you have the insight on this because God
knows how many memes are blown up right
on Instagram what the hell is going on
what these toilet papers what why toilet
I'm not getting this toilet stuff I
don't I'm not either friendly I
understand some of the things that the
supermarket okay so we're went in and
and we didn't over by it's just my wife
and our kids have grown up so Oh
the only thing were green apples the
green apples were all sitting there I
said people must not love green apples
okay
that's concern too cool maybe there's
something about the green apples you
know they're no potatoes left no onions
onions for me the big thing I'm using
the garlic if the Goblet ran out I'd
have big problems you and I both so you
go down the fish is all there there's no
problem with it because the price is so
high okay no chicken whatsoever no
turkey whatsoever and no beef the only
thing that was left was a little pork I
thought that was interesting but then
you go down see the toilet paper and the
the handle and this ain't it I've been
trying to get sanitizers not just one
bottle for three
weeks I go in early in the morning I go
in late at night I said when is this oh
well you're in the wrong place I said I
come in three times a day to just check
they can't find it so so if I understand
why they want to say it I don't get
there with the toilet paper I do not
understand that do you have a theory on
it or no my only theory is that I I
think most people don't understand that
this might be weeks not days in just
like you know before hurricane we all
run to the store and buy milk eggs and
toilet paper and water and so I think
many people believe this is kind of like
you know repair preparing for the next
storm and when we are but it's just
going to be more prolonged and I think
what we know people don't understand is
we don't need impact please people
should be encouraged not to not to go
hoard our critical infrastructures to
include our grocery stores are not going
to shut down and and the the critical
infrastructures have produced the same
things that go into our grocery stores
are not going to shut down society is
going to make sure that we had these
critical things continue to move forward
and function and so our store they're
not going to run out of toilet paper and
I think our society just you know thinks
it's this is another hurricane and
that's a good analogy but it's just
going to take it's gonna last longer and
and it's not like things are gonna be
destroyed well the way you're saying it
I would even go to the store even more
because if you tell him he's but the
critical infrastructure they're gonna be
restocked and restocked and restock or
sure you're not gonna you're not going
to need more food because of the virus
yeah okay and you can still go shop
you're not gonna need food because of
the virus you're not gonna you're gonna
eat the same line of food whether
there's a virus or not a virus yeah but
but if they do shut down and next thing
you know the grocery stores they're not
going to shut down the industries that
are producing the food and other
supplies that go in our grocery stores
and so there's really no reason to be
hoarding like like they are they're
really not I got a different kind of
question for you what are your thoughts
about if Corona by
happened in 94 not today okay so go to
94 no Facebook no YouTube not even
MySpace no Twitter no Friendster no
nothing no that's right you would be
struggling if there's no zoom none of
this stuff 94 News doesn't go like this
you don't just go all of a sudden code
update update notification notification
notification if this pandemic happened
in 1994 how different would have the
people reacted to the way media keeps
saying end of the world end of the world
and the door by the way what's what
happened we need to be stopped using
apocalyptic language okay this is media
dad well I know that but and they are
being apocalyptic but I wrote an article
actually it's called for El Al Arabiya
which is the US government's Arab
language News Service for the Middle
East and North Africa they asked me to
write a column as a former AI D it's not
well known the United State and then
marib world AI D is very well known
so they said would you is the former
administrator write something cuz people
don't know what's going on they're
afraid there's panic in the Middle East
and in North Africa and I said sure so I
wrote it and I said there's they're too
dangerous here
one is to understate the risk by
dismissing this and not listening to the
experts like dr. faux Qi and the other
is to suggest the apocalypse is upon us
and the world is about to end it's not
about to end this is nowhere near what
it was a 1918 where five percent of the
world's population died in six months we
didn't even know what a virus was then
we're just beginning to develop the germ
theory of disease okay they used to
think that it was swamp gas and
colliseum illnesses and they would still
they were still bleeding people 100
years ago they thought the the problem
was too much blood or there's something
wrong with your blood and they would
bleed you as a way of treating a disease
that was a hundred years so well we have
a much more advanced system now we have
science we know a lot more and we also
know how to produce vaccines we weren't
producing vaccines 125 years ago the way
we are now so an advanced medication you
know most of the drugs produced to the
19th century which won it there were
jokes they weren't serious back they
hurt you if took him so
we have a much more advanced system we
don't and and that means we can respond
and the structures of government are
much more sophisticated even though
people get disgusted with the government
you know who's gonna be the the big
solution of this people talk about the
Chinese model working in oh that's
baloney the Chinese model is not a
superior model to our mo our model is
highly decentralized at the state and
local level most of the response is not
taking place at the federal level that's
the most visible because the news media
from its what the 50 governors are doing
all the mayors the boards of Selectmen
in New England ryu originally kind of
came from the county judges in texas
they are the ones who run the systems
that we actually connect with who runs
the school systems the federal
government doesn't run any fools
how many universities there right none
how many factories they run it's a
highly decentralized system and what's
amazing to me is if you watch what's
happening across the country people are
simply saying I see the threat I'm the
leader of an institution I want to
protect my people which is my job and
that's what they're doing across the
country so what's the big news
that is the best very good news that we
as a democracy are taking responsibility
at our own level not saying over in a
ways for someone from Washington tell us
how to fix this which is not a good idea
that's what we did yesterday we made a
list of people that have kids who they
can't find people and you know day care
to take care of them so they're working
from home and folks that are above 50
years old are working from home and then
we made a list of anybody that's
pregnant anybody that has any kind of a
health based on the conversations that
they have they're all working from home
and you know we can have a few people
that are working from here we made that
decision yesterday so I agree with that
but the question I want to ask you in 94
what the US government in 94 have
reacted the way we are reacting today
what a amount of fear that's in people
right now because of social media would
happen would the steps and the way the
government reacted in 94 been the same
as it is today actually is it social
media that's driving some of the fear as
opposed to you know public health
authorities in in media because I think
I think a lot of actually the Director
General the world hell
organization described before he
declared a pandemic that we are actually
in an endemic and so what we have now is
we have an empire 100% oh so much
misleading information fear-mongering
and trying to get anxiety and worry in
people and so it's it's simple demek and
it's the fear is actually much worse
than covet and so somehow we got to do a
better that does tell me that we need to
do a better job as a society and in in
risk communication and communicating you
know what the what the risks are and
what we're doing about it and counter
this this misinformation is that is an
implement media maybe we would have been
better in 94 without the proliferation
of social what I'm saying well III agree
with one of the things that's happening
is people are taking advantage of this
to make money they're apparently they
confiscated fake testing kits at one of
the ports but where we're at
I think was in Los Angeles West Coast
somewhere they I saw it this morning on
the news it was very interesting to
someone has produced a it's not a test
kit but it looks like one and it's a
fake and people trying to make money on
it
there are people running around saying
that if you can hold your breath for a
certain number of seconds that you don't
have the disease that's complete
nonsense does it damage your lungs in
later stages yes but by that time
frankly it's gonna knock on them you're
gonna have testing they can tell you you
have holding your breath he's not going
to tell you where the heavy the disease
or not the third thing that I've heard
now is that if you breathe in a hundred
and thirty three degree steam into your
system will kill the virus it's utter
nonsense
you could singe your lungs if you do it
I don't know what how how bad hundred
actually have been 133 wait but that's
not gonna kill the virus it's ridiculous
to talk about things like that
so people should be very careful if you
want to find out what to do go on the
Center for Disease Control website they
give you advice these are the top
scientists that's religious makes yes if
you really need to keep you keep doing
that driving people to authoritative
sources and actually I would he actually
in
urge people in their communities
wherever you may live is go to your
local public health websites first good
idea because you it's your local public
health your local emergency management
your local community has got the most
authoritative up to date information for
the community you live in and then the
CDC has got the most authority and they
get their guidance and recommendation
from the CDC and then apply it to their
local communities but anything you can
do to continue to promote people going
to authority Authority sources of
information will be very good we're
actually looking at at a group that does
kind of artificial intelligence has they
you know to look at social media but
we're trying to perhaps use a group that
can help us identify how misinformation
is is bubbling up through social media
to also kind of counter it with the
right improves we by the way when you
well I can't talk as it's a proprietary
company to somebody yeah you know I will
tell you I would love to do that all the
line just making introductions some of
the fantastics because because we need
we need to do that and try to put some
counter and counter measures of vaccine
against social media bad social media
because social media is also very
important to it's a good way that we
communicate and get information out but
we just have to counter the the
misinformation there is a statement now
I've heard on this that this was all a
conspiracy to defeat the president
regardless of that's just nonsense do
you think that the Italians created this
what's happening Italy I think it's all
made up that's ridiculous so the Chinese
made up 80,000 their people dying and
collapsed the economy in order to affect
our president John that's not what's
happening
so people these conspiracy theories on
the left and the right are not helpful
well you can't tell people to stop doing
what they'll do it anyway but I'm just
telling you it's not helpful in it's
nonsense this is a real problem it's a
crisis it is not the apocalypse so we
have to be we can't create public panic
on the other one we need to take the
steps necessary to get this under
control
has who's the big whistleblower the two
big whistleblowers what are their names
I'm curious to know if any of these
whistleblowers are coming out and given
any kind of insight because eventually
some of this news is going to come out
you know the main whistleblower in China
was a doctor who came out saying this is
this is bigger than we think it is yes
and then he died he died from
very well I was very personally he's 37
years old she went in a high-risk group
I don't think he was a high-risk group I
think they made like a conspiracy theory
so the question was why did the 37 year
old I well but but but to go there with
you I am not far from where you are okay
with what you're saying so we're on the
same what's your opinions on China I've
had general Spalding here was a general
in the Air Force anyone and you know
what he did yeah he did some work on
China and he came here and he he held
nothing back on China nothing uh you
know I mean he talked about five g's
effects on what they're trying to do
with made in China 2025 had I want to
take over the world etc etc it was not
altering there but I don't your thoughts
on China what I think that we are
exaggerating let me tell you when I was
I'm 70 years old so I remember when I
was in my 20s articles and all a news
media that the Japanese model is going
to take over the whole world even a
country of had 100 million people how
they're gonna take over the whole world
and the Japanese model their industrial
system is far superior to us you read
anything like that in the last 30 years
know why the Japanese model was had deep
problems with it so did it's a Chinese
model do you know what the Chinese have
they have a highly educated technocracy
very well very gifted scientists very
smart people and they're good business
people and they've collected a lot of
money we've got a billion and a half no
most of you however are dollars in their
sovereign wealth fund okay you know what
they have that we that we have that they
don't have we have very strong highly
functional resilient institutions you
know what makes a society and this is
what I teach in my courses what's the
difference between a poor country in a
rich country it's not they have rich
riches in the rich countries to have
institutions that produce wealth the
Chinese have weak and corrupted
institutions they're trying to fix him
they did you know how many how many law
schools there were in 1980 in China for
four they had 2,000 lawyers in the whole
country you cannot have a modern car
me without a legal system no rule of law
no economy you have to have a rule of
law okay Milton Friedman assumed when
the Soviet Union collapsed that all they
had to do was free the markets up and
everything would be great at the end of
the 1990s he was at the Cato Institute a
libertarian history said we made a
terrible mistake no rule of law no
economic growth and there's a whole
school of institutional economics to say
that the Chinese have profound
dysfunctions in their system which we
are not seeing we're creating a threat
is there a threat yes there is we need
to deal with it we're seeing in the
pharmaceutical in to directly address it
but let's not make some mythological
powerful figure out there of a country
when in fact they have deep internal
problems and David by the way they
recognize it even talked to Chinese
privately they'll tell you what there if
you go on I don't read read Mandarin
Chinese but some of my friends do they
said you should see the rage of the
Chinese people against their own
government it's unbelievable they're
saying things they would never say in a
totalitarian or autocratic system
because of the level of anger they
believed the government lied to them
they believed that they knew about this
was going on for two months before they
did anything and they're very very
there's a lot of anger there's a lot of
fear in the Chinese government of an
uprising in China like they had in
Tiananmen Square wasn't by the way just
10 min Square in 1979 when there was
uprising in China was across the country
that the center of it was in Beijing
they were afraid of that happening again
there have been four shocks to China and
the last year this is the fourth one
they had this shock with the with the
African swine flu for prices are up
which is a principal source approaching
there 130 hundred forty percent rise of
prices in China that upset people a lot
you know there are huge price increases
before tenements square that's one of
the things that drove it in 1979 the
uprising in China same things happening
now with price increases and you have a
lot of money being spent to keep
factories producing things that no one
wants why are they doing that because
they're afraid of unemployment causing
social unrest in the country so
they have a lot of internal problems but
we do need to understand they've been
manipulating the international system
against us
there are Minutemen the Russians of
doing the same thing they're using
social media to defeat us and we need to
be more aware of it
half of the anti-vaccine movement is
coming from Russia from these Autobots
they're attempting to turn Americans
socialism you know the social media and
misinformation campaign that's exactly
what it is they're running around saying
the US military planted this virus in
China that's a bold-faced lie it's
absolutely outrageous why are they doing
they're trying to deflect attention from
their own failures in the early stages
of this now did they act later yes they
did but the thing was loose for two
months what were they doing those two
months nothing they're suppressing the
information a democracy cannot suppress
information because Free Press free
associations civil society all of our
institutions just don't permit it they
do cannot suppress information in a
democracy
I don't trust any country that is ran on
a one-party system where there's no Free
Press or free speech where the country
controls the data I don't I don't trust
any of it
China has been saying their
unemployment's been between 2.8 percent
of 90% the last 30 years you have you
out of your mind to say you're employing
1.5 billion people and only 3% of them
don't have jobs so and you were what
what what I'm what I'm concerned about
what why is there a community of people
in America on media that are constantly
protecting China I've had so many strong
debates myself with some of the most
powerful people in the world that
protect China and it goes over and over
and over and they keep protecting China
why is there a community protecting try
now to understand this part what's your
opinion on it you're on it all the time
well there are some people who have
vested interests economic interests
intellectual interests they may have
friends in China they may be dealing
with the Chinese government that's one
group of people of a conflict of
interest I understand them okay I
actually understand let's set those
aside there's a second group of people
now I have some friends in this
community as well to say
if we start provoking the Chinese and
they are really suffering internal
problems they could become extremely
aggressive internationally they have a
large land army and we could face a war
with them we do not want to have a war
with China
we don't want to have a war with China
it's it would be a catastrophe from both
countries and for the world
we don't need World War 3 nuclear or not
forget the nuclear part of it ok we do
not want a conventional war with China
the latter though the loss of a human
population whether it's in the military
or not would be enormous so they're the
people who say well we just look the
other way
ok we were just when it was norther
respect their system
why not respect their system if they're
cheating and the rules and they're using
the rules I think to their own advantage
against us and I have a problem with
that as many increasingly by the way the
Chinese think well if Trump are in
office this would go away nonsense
the Democrats are saying the same thing
now it's not a partisan question anymore
and stop I can say that as well yes the
pharmaceutical ish issue I mean I'm a
free trader from a suitable issue I
didn't realize this before we started
studying this we by the way we we we
brought this issue up in our white paper
in 2018 this is not something we just
read order an article for they were
circular around the world but our white
paper that's been on our website for two
years now we said this was a problem two
years ago no one listened to it now
they're listening to it they've been
congressional hearings on this and all
that so those issues we need to confront
the Chinese on but what we don't need is
to push them so far that we have a
conflict with them I mean a military
conflict which is what these things
sometimes descend into you have a
different opinion on that oh yeah same
oh you know I've I would add just maybe
one more category and I'll speak kind of
like from my public health colleagues
and that in that world and we we like to
collaborate we like to trust people and
there's been a lot of say Chinese
scientists that have trained in the
United States and so there's a lot of
there's a lot of you know I guess friend
friendly relationships and colleagues in
the public health and science community
between the US and China
so there's another factor and that's
naivete mmm that you know although that
you know we are colleagues on kind of
that professional level too many don't
realize that they may have there's only
so far they can collaborate and that
they may be using that friendship and
collaboration to a bigger strategic
advantage so there's naivete is another
component of that I can totally see that
I have two more questions for before we
wrap up virus coins money phone where it
lives you hear a lot of different data
12 hours 18 hours clothes dogs pets sex
what can you tell us about the lifespan
of this virus talk about all of that
well I mean you you can take any part
you want you got kids so you know about
sex so what can you tell us about any of
this stuff on how a person could get you
know coronavirus well I think you know
the primary mode of transmission of
coronavirus is going to be person to
person that's going to be droplet so in
when we call our Steve's and it's the
droplets that come out of our mouth and
and fortunately those droplets are
falling to the ground and that's why
this this social separation is
recommended at six feet so that's really
the primary means of transmission now
there are you know we're beginning to
understand what is what is the
environmental half-life of the virus if
it's on a table on a doorknob and so
forth so some of those reports are
coming out and it may be in days as
opposed to minutes you know there's
gonna be much more so that's that's part
of that category at some of the sciences
we'd unknown unknown but we're beginning
to fill in the gaps and fill in the
holes but it's really you know that that
droplet transmission from person to
person is really the primary means a
trance transmission for now for a
healthcare worker and the hospital
particularly they may be doing some type
of procedure caring for a patient that
might it could create an aerosol in an
OP in the room which behaves more it may
spread more than a droplet but that's
really kind of a special unique
situation in the healthcare kind of
delivery and in the hospital situation
so that's why the simple tried-and-true
infection control measures at the
personal level are so important
wash your hands with soap and water
and for 20 seconds and they'll sing the
Happy Birthday song that's about 20
seconds as you know as a reminder and
you know if you're sick stay home
and if you need to seek medical care by
all means do but call the head so you
know what the procedures are where you
should go so that you're not they will
give you instructions of how to how to
come in and you know call fatik it
that's all you know extremely important
so really it's how do you avoid exposure
how do you avoid exposing others you
know kind of think in those simple terms
but it's it's absolutely essential to
make sure we take take those simple
things so droplets six feet I mean these
are some good droplets if you can go
with six feet by the way it's like
they're tiny tiny tiny I'm giving you
but that's what we know that's what we
should do I don't know I wash my hands
before I eat
long before the virus I get sick very
few times because that the principle
mechanism other than droplets is dirty
hands I have come to a conclusion that
you want to make sure the folks below 50
stop working I've come to the conclusion
that that's what you are my kids are
below 50 I don't want them to you want
us or stop working so okay last last
last question and this is this is my
biggest concern I'm not concerned about
coronavirus and what I mean by I'm not
concerned don't get me wrong I don't
mean you know I'm not I'm being
irresponsible and I got a wife and three
kids and we're not taking the right
measures no I was in LA we had a board
meeting I got the news I told my wife
will go back to LA it was a spring break
for the kids we're trying to take them
Universal Studios my board meeting I'll
cancel we came back the same day were
supposed to say three four days we're
doing this stuff at the company
everything were being responsible what
we need to do as a company okay let's
set that part aside I'm not worried
about coronavirus because I went and
looked at the numbers of how infectious
it is they know there are zero number
whatever that number is that you know
that that shows like I say it again are
not are not yeah the number they looking
at on how infectious it is and how
measles was like twelve to sixteen and
then once is fourteen sixteen for
measles yeah it's one two two two three
four coronavirus on a virus it's it's
twice is is infectious as the flu is it
is but here's the part that's not
my question forget about chrono virus
forget about coronavirus my concerns not
coronavirus because yes these are still
bad numbers you know 1% estimate died
and you know code 919 1.9 to 2.8
whatever then i'm 121.9 a 1/2 with to
point us the numbers I got that I'm
looking at from see I see
okay I'm not worried about this what are
we gonna do because Ebola was 50% death
rate MERS was 34 point for smallpox 30
percent SARS 9.6 what are we gonna do in
the future 10 years 20 years 30 years
you're in the world that's 30 years from
now when when white paves are all about
this if if and I want to get the answers
we're gonna put your white papers book
what are we gonna do in the future where
we get a virus that is both as
infectious as measles and both as deadly
as Ebola right what are we going to do
there to be able to prevent that from
all of a sudden after population in the
world dying well first let me just take
you know why some viruses spread around
the world and some do not at the end of
the day a virus needs to have a living
host and so a bowl on the you know the
bad news is it's over 40 50 percent
lethality but also those who catch a
bola you know they have it and that's
why containment measures with Ebola are
so effective or can be effective it
doesn't get out of control so you can
actually control Ebola it we might have
another crisis like we had in West
Africa or what's happening right now in
the DRC but it did not spread around the
world could it spread further in the
world sure because of our globalization
but each virus is different and some of
these really high lethality viruses they
need a living host and and that's why
containment type measures are extremely
important so we can stop it so it
doesn't keep finding a living host now
that's why cope it is concerning is it
it has it it has a case fatality rate
that's a lot lower actually but you know
saves 1% but if it spreads around the
world and you know infects
just in the United States now some of
the numbers you're using earlier 60 70
he will have her mini you know if it's
in that range well that 1% fatality rate
actually is pretty concerning and in in
and so that that number is kind of high
but what we have to do this is this is
really let me get to what we need to be
doing first we need to be taking
emerging infectious diseases much more
seriously than we have in the past I
agree that is that really is the issue
and these are actually they've become
not just in the domain of Public Health
these are really national security
issues health security issues and so we
actually have some of the tools at hand
that can actually begin if we focus our
efforts to begin to think about
prevention in the first place it's going
to court require some investment but we
first we've got to start taking emerging
infectious diseases much more seriously
than we do today
and maybe covet 19 is a wake up call
but guess what SARS was supposed to be a
wake-up call 2009 a pandemic that was
supposed to be a wake-up call o bola in
the West Africa in 2014 2016 that was
supposed to be a wake-up call I just
hope we can not push the snooze button
after this is Oh what do we do is what I
mean do that that I can tell you from
personal experience the role of aid
agencies like USAID and our NGO
community and our contractors and elf
contractors is to build the capacity of
developing countries to deal with their
own problems so that they can control
these infections before they get out of
hand the trends now are that 75 percent
of the 40 new diseases that have come up
infected people human beings in the last
50 years are from animals wild animals
and domesticated mostly wild animals but
domestic animals now the institutions
don't exist in many of these countries
to prevent this from happening
they can prevent it they can reduce it
those wet markets in China where they
saw living animals have been a problem
for decades the Chinese government would
not do anything of them now banned them
they should abandon a long time ago and
they know that but they didn't want to
do because it's very unpopular
politically there's a study that was
done of the hiv/aids program that
President Bush started and that
President Obama continued that's not a
partisan question and on
malaria program by Senator Daschle was a
Republican Emma Craddock senator he was
a Republican Democratic majority leader
in the Senate or II and was it built
Forest Hill for instance Bill Frist is
the Republican leader inside so the
Republican a Democrat
former senators they here they they run
this bipartisan Center on policy and
they looked at why Ebola didn't spread
in Africa why was it contained in only
three countries and it's because the
hiv/aids program and the malaria program
built the capacity of the Nigerian
Center for Disease Control there's no
big outbreak in Nigeria it's a huge
country it's a quarter of Africa is
Nigeria
why didn't it get Lucis right next door
it's because the Nigerian Center for
Disease Control that was trained by
USAID and the Center for Disease can our
Center for Disease Control CDC together
they helped build this Institute and
that Nigerians built and it was very
effective in preventing the virus from
spreading into Nigeria so one thing
that's not very popular a lot a lot of
people is to have aid programs that
build institutions and other countries
to deal with this because the only way
to deal with these outbreaks is right in
the country itself that's what we're
most of these dangerous viruses are
emerging in in low middle income
countries where we lack you know they
they lack the public health
institutional capacities and so that's
where you know foreign aid can be very
critical because we can if we can
prevent if we can first detect an
outbreak there then and if we give them
the tools to be able to respond they can
stop the outbreak before it becomes a
regional epidemic or RER pandemic and so
that's that's why these international
law that's one thing we can do yeah we
need to fix the federal government I
mean I don't mean the whole government I
mean with respect to pen there's a whole
bunch of questions that have not been
resolved about who is responsible for
what and how you you you turn the switch
on when you turn the emergency response
system on now when I'm going to go into
it here but Jerry is a member of the
what's the name bipartisan Commission
for bio defense yes
and I tested he asked me to testify
before it I did we and he's very I mean
you should read their report it's a very
powerful report
needs to be done so there are issues
that have not been settled because
senior policymakers in both parties have
not seen until now this to be an issue
SARS may have been a wake-up call jury
but people saw into the newspaper didn't
affect them personally that's right
this is history strain middle distance
and streets this is not something to
take lightly you know you know when you
grow up you're you you you fear nuclear
war oh my gosh you know nuclear war and
then the last 15 years you're hearing
their body saying you know it's not
gonna be nuclear it's gonna be a cyber
war that's what it's gonna be well I
mean the easiest way to manipulate any
kind of war and try to hurt the country
is through a bio warfare which you know
you guys study is so to me and when I
sit and look at the numbers see how my
data common math guy I'm a guy that
studies exponential growth we started a
business from 66 agents to 14,000 agents
in 40 United States because the whole
idea was about how can we exponentially
grow so it's the only thing I paid
attention to in high school and college
was math only thing everything else I
could care less about right so when I
look at data I look at it from a
different perspective that concerns me
you know here's one thing you said you
said you're able to control in the
country so this happens in Hubei Wuhan
which is part of a 50 to 60 million
people live in that area whatever the
number is you 450 over 60 and then it
goes to Thailand first country I think
that has the case and then it goes
Thailand in somehow comes to us because
the guy was traveling to Washington who
was just in China 30 year old guy gets
it first case and then so then all over
750 hundred state how many countries
were out right now I don't know the
exact things hundred sixty plus will be
all right now and it's not as infectious
as some of these other ones right so my
challenge becomes if you have a daughter
and she's 18 years old she's dating a
boy who has AIDS not because he got it
from sex but because maybe his mother
had it and the blood
something something what I'm trying to
tell you is would you let your daughter
date this guy wouldn't you have certain
fears so if we know China has a wet
market why is us okay with you know the
travel they're not creating more travel
restrictions if you know what why does
the country like us who has the
authority to tell China
listen if you don't clean house with the
way you have these kinds of things I'm
which is not doing business with you
we're not gonna let your people travel
to us so to meet this the concern of me
long-term as a parent and as a person
that runs a business goes to travel if
we don't if this this has to be
addressed through travel if it's not
addressed through travel and it's too
easy of doing that with every country
eventually if somebody has the virus
gonna be Momo Momo will come to you you
never know where it's coming from I
don't know the answer is it going to
cause a re review a rethinking of supply
chains a profound rethinking of supply I
hope so yes not just the pharmaceutical
in this industry because now Apple
realizes they've got five countries or
seven countries producing the components
of an iPhone that's produced in China if
one of those sequential parts of the
supply chain shut down they can't
produce the iPhone they've created a
system that's highly efficient keeps the
price down that's America I know that's
America's fault I'm sorry that's a mere
ice ball you're right because two
reasons the consumer wants to pay
cheaper and entrepreneur wants to sell
it for make bigger profits right guess
what this probably gonna be 20% more but
guess what what it's made in America
period it's made in u.s. you don't want
it don't buy it right you know if you
want if I go buy a cheaper product
that's made in US but it's not as good
of a product don't you don't have to buy
this thing but III do think you're
seeing more and more bragging rights
about companies saying made in US I
think that's gonna go into a whole a
different level when I'm seeing a
company say made in u.s. I want to buy
the product and support let me mention
one last thing we could do we could sent
up CDC was trying to do it AI D was
trying to do it we the funding has been
cut off from it no one took it too
seriously
AI D was identifying the 2,000 viruses
that are the ones that because they're
like 150,000 viruses they've been done
to five something I don't know what the
exact number but it's an enormous number
but most of them are not a threat they
identified through a project that AI D
ran with funding from the Congress that
came out of I think that 19 the Ebola
was out of the Ebola supplemental budget
and it created a system for identifying
those viruses and then setting up a cent
surveillance system around the world to
give us early warning we have an early
warning system for famines that we
started in 1985 there's been a
substantial drop of the first time in
150 the first time in history there's
been a massive drop in famine deaths is
because we have an early warning system
to tell us when this is about to happen
we need an early warning system around
the world when these virus outbreaks
take place and to give us the time you
know what the biggest problem is in the
response is time Oh three weeks in an
emergency response and a fast onset
disaster like this is a huge amount of
time if you made decisions you know the
first week that this happens I agree can
stop it I totally agree yes but you need
a surveillance system yeah but you can't
do it if it's in another country that's
not doing it at the levels that you're
doing it at that's that's what I'm
saying and said if you're not in charge
of that if it you can set up a system
you you may be able to set up a system
but if they don't want to follow the
rules you totalitarian dude what are you
gonna tell them how to stand that I
understand that but there's a way
checking what's going on in other
countries without actually being
yourself in terms of Americans in those
countries so we we have to do more to
get earlier warning we have to do more
internationally to build capacity and
try to prevent an outbreak anywhere it
starts from becoming an epidemic but we
also have to do more in our own country
so whenever we do have a major outbreak
like what a pandemic that we can respond
better in the United States and we have
to have incentives that the private
sector is more part of the solution we
can't be too totally dependent upon say
the CDC for laboratory testing as an
example and so we we need to have if we
we need to have systems in place that
the private sectors part of the
preparedness activity from the start we
can't just turn it on like a switch when
there's a crisis find a way to make it
profitable to absent you know absolutely
yeah it's hard but we we've been talking
about a long time but we got to figure
that out you find a way to give them
that credit by the way anything fight
this five do you have anything to do
with this or not at all you've seen some
you've seen any reports would 5gn this
or not it I have not nothing okay couple
one the conspiracies five of you by the
way I don't know if you've seen that the
conspiracy the vibe to G go look it up
that is related to this oh yeah oh yeah
they're saying that five
gee with the waves is helping this thing
spread I don't know if I follow any of
this stuff with 5g5 just thread on well
that's a whole different topic I don't
want to go to it all I can say is this I
really enjoyed this conversation I want
to say it's a couple hours to me it
feels like five minutes thank you so
much for your help and coming out and
giving us all the insight and being
willing to take some of the questions
and push back because that's how we all
learn and hopefully of this thing if we
can if we have more question and this is
formulating a little more in the
audience once you guys back hopefully we
can invite you guys back than a few
thank you very much for coming up I'd
shake your hands but you know why we yes
thanks guys thank you by the way if you
watch this interview you want some of
those papers that we're talking about
police click on a link but we're gonna
leave it for you and on top and I got
two other videos I want you to watch one
of them is an interview I did with
General Spaulding General of Air Force
who went and lived in China as part of
his project then his duty and he came
back and he gave a talk one time that
got him in trouble in the ended up
getting fired it's a very very powerful
video talks about 5g and a bunch of
different things that China is doing and
then the other video is a video I did on
coronavirus that talks about how
coronavirus shut down the world and it's
very very deep if you have a watch just
won't click on this one if you want to
watch General Spaulding do that and if
you haven't subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care buh bye
you
[Music]